on a bien négocié les mistoufle il y en
avait beaucoup on était souvent ville
avec des boucles qui tombe et c'est pas
très rassurant parce qu'en fait on
n'était jamais bien équilibrée fallait
fallait éviter le chavirage et puis on
sait on a dû passer au bon endroit j'ai
l'impression parce que les autres sont
un peu moins bien passé que nous donc on
est plutôt contents et après on avait
une petite avance devant et voilà on est
c'est terminé
sans trop de mal parce que notre
concurrent direct était deuxième comme
il a été souvent pendant cette semaine
mais il n'était pas loin à chaque fois
il est bien parti et donc ça a été une
bagarre contre lui à un moment et
ensuite on a un petit peu creuse est
donc parfait le bilan de la journée le
titre de champion du monde
bah c'est très sympa c'est pas forcément
une discipline où je suis est trop
habitués à venir mais c'est à chaque
fois un très grand plaisir et et le
faire des raids avec ses petits bateaux
c'est vraiment génial surtout qu'il ya
35 bateaux et ça navigue bien
tactiquement il ya plein de choses à
faire et il faut être très concentré sur
ces bateaux pour que ça avance donc
c'est une régate très très complète donc
être champion du monde c'est toujours un
titre on va prendre ça avec évidemment
plaisir et souriant j'espère j'espère
ouais ouais si c'est le sinon programme
le permet carrément j'aimerais revenir
les concurrents cession s'il avait pas
de concurrent la course très facile et
heureusement car des concurrents parce
que c'est comme ça que c'est intéressant
et
non il ya eu au vendredi il ya eu
beaucoup les sargasses quand même à
gérer
c'est un peu au petit bonheur la chance
donc c'est jamais très agréable mais il
fallait en enlever souvent et sinon
c'est comme d'habitude bien gérer le
bateau bien gérer les effets de site le
vent il est forcément très instables au
tour de l'île et
et donc faire les anticiper pour être du
bon côté à chaque fois stratégiquement
et
dans ce cas là dans ce cas là on creuse
rapidement des écarts mais en fait
toujours des erreurs il faut en faire un
petit peu moins que les autres